you
hey youtubers is charlie new Supergirl
season to take off footage Man of Steel
style we also got a whole bunch of stuff
from the first couple of episodes so
let's break it down most of you probably
remember this from the first Man of
Steel trailer way way back it seems like
a lifetime ago that movie debuted it's
also kind of a nod to the Smallville
Superman take off this is the way the
Clark would take off the few times that
he did fly on that TV show
they were like times really early on
where he briefly flew and then way later
during the final season the show but
really I think this is more of a
reference to the Man of Steel trailer
but it's just a clever way for them to
hype the supergirls now on the CW show
that it's getting a little bit more
hardcore just going to be a lot more fun
like they've already dropped a whole
bunch of season 2 images and there is a
bunch of Superman picks but I guess
they're holding him for like the
official big trailer this is kind of
like a teaser but they kind of work out
to that like they'll slowly ramp up like
when they were getting ready to drop the
flash trailer they dropped a couple
teasers first so Superman footage is
around the corner and we know a bunch
about the first two episodes we know
that Cadmus labs sends metallo after
both Superman and Supergirl that's what
creates the need for the team-up for
Superman to leave metropolis because you
have to imagine that there's disasters
happening all over the world at all time
so Superman is understandably super busy
but will pop up throughout the season
when there's an a-list problem or when
it's super girls turn to buy the donuts
and the other big thing is they're
actually showing off Lena luthor played
by Katie McGrath so what they explained
a comic and this raises a bunch of
questions clear like hey we have Luthor
Corp where's Lex Luthor so they said in
this continuity Lex Luthor just like
movie Lex Luthor Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor is in prison so Lena Luthor who
was like the test Mercer character on
Smallville I'll explain that in a second
but she's stepped up and taken over
Luthor Corp in wants to pull their name
out of the mud because it's still a
multinational billion-dollar corporation
so she's definitely not as evil seeming
as her brother that doesn't mean that
she won't butt heads with Supergirl on
Superman but you look at her here and
she does look fantastically evil like
Merlin during arrow season 1 and if
you've read Supergirl comics from like
way back in the 90s then you know that
there was a version of Supergirl who
hung out
is kind of like the boyfriend confidant
of the red hair Lex Luthor so maybe
we'll see some deep cuts from that but
no idea if we're going to see any actual
collaboration between LuthorCorp and
Cadmus labs Cadmus labs is supposed to
be like the big bad of season two so
metallo comes in the first episode it's
just kind of like the tip of the iceberg
like look at all the crazy toys we're
going to unleash on Supergirl and
Superman so the title of the first
episode is called The Adventures of
Supergirl that's also the name of the
comic book that they're doing right now
like they started a new Supergirl comic
that tied in with the TV show called The
Adventures of Supergirl and there's also
a Supergirl rebirth comic that's a
little more in keeping with the tone of
the TV show even though it's not quite
the same thing like the comics will
always be their own separate thing but
there'll always be a lot of Easter eggs
in the TV show for stuff that's
happening so the adventures of Supergirl
is the title of episode 1 the title of
episode 2 the last children of Krypton
is actually a riff on a Superman title
written by Geoff Johns and Superman
director Richard Donner that's right
Richard Donner actually wrote a Superman
comic book with Geoff Johns so it was
called the last Son of Krypton so now we
have two kids so it's like the last
children to Krypton so you understand
you can read that but obviously they're
not going to do exact comic-book plot
they always change little things but
sometimes it's fun if you know they're
doing like a specific comic book title
to go and read that to see what kind of
Easter eggs they're gonna do from that
story but also in keeping with that
theme you guys probably know that Kevin
Smith is doing an episode of season 2
it's titled Supergirl lives and he said
when he found out he started to cry
because that was actually based on the
title of his failed Superman script
called Superman lives like he had
written a treatment of a Superman movie
way before Man of Steel ever happened so
we know Kevin Smith cries about
everything but it's just really touching
the links they're going to in season 2
to do comic book Easter egg things for
really big stuff that's happened in
Superman and supergirls history so I
know everybody's waiting to see actual
footage of season 2 we're within the one
month window of Supergirl dropping like
it drops October 10th so there'll be
little stuff like this happening every
week I would expect like a full big
trailer in the next week or two
definitely something big going to happen
when the flash and arrow premiere
because they per
or the week before Supergirl so they're
probably going to use that to also
promote all the other DC shows on the CW
so a whole bunch of stuff is happening
Supergirl hypetrain
taken off there is a new round of the DC
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video what's going to happen
next is is Robert Downey jr. posted like
the most teaser picture that you could
possibly tease of a Marvel project but
you have the Russos that are doing
infinity war and you have Kevin Feige
who's kind of like the Godfather of all
Marvel films so then Jon Favreau who's a
long time Iron Man director meeting just
means that they are planning larger
things beyond spider-man homecoming in
infinity war so I'll do a video for that
next I should post later tonight while
you guys wait for all the Iron Man force
stuff to post you can click here for my
Avengers infinity war behind the scenes
video you can click here for all my
other spider-man homecoming thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
Oh